vous avez mis quoi comme essence la
moins chère d'accord oui pas mal mais
chez moi
[Musique]
prune au
d'habitude je mets des coupés dans le
réservoir ça marche même pas là vous
avez quoi comme essence la moins chère
des records oui pas mal mais chez moi
[Musique]
prennent aux écoles moi je vais bosser
lavier marc tu vas te [ __ ] dans le
canapé et tu veux regarder des dessins
animés
c'est quoi ça ok on va sonner ils vont
ouvrir alors qu'arte c'est quoi ton
excuses aujourd'hui calmer ses
démonstrations vieillit ça va pas la
tête de dire d'être comme ça on a dit
que c'était fini c'est bhl est vaguement
classique c'est important l'école est
bien pour lui mais comment faire on fait
pas créé chez vous faites enfants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu restes là pas bougé tu restes là moi
je suis un ami de prune toi tu équipe
super je manquerais pour moi ce que je
veux c'est mon frère ok d'accord
vous êtes tous frères et soeurs en fait
vous êtes juste 3 où il y en a d'autres
[Musique]